President Trump and Speaker Pelosi snipe
at each other Julian Assange faces
charges in we checked the mailbag I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
well it's a busy Friday the president
also declassifying all sorts of material
via his Attorney General William Power
we'll get to that Theresa May the Prime
Minister of Britain stepping down we'll
get to that as well it's all these
things but first you've heard me talk
about helix mattresses for years helix
makes the best and most comfortable
mattresses designed to fit your unique
body type and sleep preferences and now
the makers of helix bring you a new
brand focused on organic all-natural
mattresses is called birch the birch
mattress isn't just comfortable it's
also great for the environment it's made
with all-natural materials breathable
wool sustainably sourced directly from
New Zealand farmers organic latex tapped
from rubber trees sustainable steel
springs that contour to your body birch
is one of the best and most affordable
organic mattresses out there and has a
25-year warranty free shipping and get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
if you don't like it they'll pick it up
and give you a full refund and right now
Berkshire is offering two hundred bucks
off all mattress orders for our
listeners just go to birch bir ch
living.com slash pen for $200 off your
mattress order that is birch living.com
slash been for 200 bucks off your
mattress order right now I love my own
helix sleep mattress and now this new
brand environmentally friendly also
brings a vault sounds great birch
living.com slash been for 200 bucks off
your mattress order which is a pretty
spectacular deal once more birch
living.com slash man bir ch living.com
slash pen alrighty so we begin today
with the crazy fight between President
Trump and Nancy Pelosi so we as we've
been discussing for the past several
days Nancy Pelosi the Democrats strategy
for 2020 is to make Donald Trump appear
to be a crazy person this is their chief
strategy and Nancy Pelosi is basically a
suicide bomber doing this well I mean I
don't mean literally obviously I mean
politically speaking Nancy Pelosi has
basically strapped down the crazy vest
and she says if I act crazy it will get
Trump to act crazy
I'm only elected by the people of San
Francisco president Trump is elected by
the people of the United States and that
means people in San Francisco don't care
if I'm crazy but people broadly across
the United States do care if Trump is
crazy so in a crazy fight Trump is
always going to lose because the
referendum is going to be on Trump as
president
United States everybody understands what
Nancy Pelosi is at this point and it
doesn't matter because again if she's
elected by crazy people in San Francisco
Donald Trump has to win a majority of
the voters of the United States at least
in the electoral college it's hard to do
that when people widely perceive you as
being volatile Nancy Pelosi knows that
and that is why she has been basically
jabbing at President Trump over and over
and over again saying that he's engaged
in a cover-up saying that he's unstable
and all this sort of stuff President
Trump because he's a counter-puncher has
a natural tendency to then engage in
precisely the reverse sort of behavior
which is to rip on his political
opponents and also to get supremely
defensive about his own mental status so
Nancy Pelosi said yesterday that
President Trump wants us to impeach him
this is what she says that President
Trump is a crazy person he's getting
nothing done and he wants us to impeach
him in order to save himself
here is the Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi jabbing at Trump deliberately
deliberately poking at Trump in an
attempt to get Trump to fire back at her
in the most volatile possible fashion
house is just crying out that's why it
slipped yesterday because he he was
hoping when he saw that see he's saying
oh you called that meeting at nine
o'clock no we have meeting mr. president
it's not about you that was what
disappointed him because he didn't see
this rush to impeachment coming out of
our caucus in our nine o'clock meeting
which he thought was called specifically
for him
okay so then President Trump fired back
so with with Nancy Pelosi jabbing at him
over and over and over
president Trump fired back yesterday
repeatedly so first Trump ripped crying
Chuck and crazy Nancy he did this in the
Roosevelt Room of the White House
flanked by farmers who he was giving a
sort of bailout to in the aftermath of
his Chinese trade war here's President
Trump ripping into crime truck and crazy
Nancy Ann again as I've been saying for
days I have a lot of sympathy on an
emotional level for president Trump
who's being slapped around by Democrats
who's being unfairly treated by
Democrats I really do think that these
in bed
negations are not directed toward
criminal activity they're directed
toward getting under Trump's skin
Democrats have successfully done that
and that's why the president should not
allow them to look that's a hard job
I've been through myself it's very rough
but the president if he wants to win
reelection this is not the strategy for
doing it here's the president ripping
into crying Chuck and crazy Nancy she
said I walked into the room right next
door yesterday and walked in and started
screaming and yelling just the opposite
just the opposite
because I know that they will always say
that even if it didn't happen because
this happened once before I walked out I
was so calm so I walked into the Cabinet
Room you had the the group cryin Chuck
crazy Nancy I tell you what I've been
watching her and I have I have been
watching her for a long period of time
she's not the same person she's lost it
hey he's fairing back and listen as a
Republican as a conservative Nancy
Pelosi has a lot of this coming but
that's not really the question the
question is is this strategically smart
for the president to get down in the mud
with Nancy Pelosi and have a crazy fight
when again he is the one who's going to
be up for presidential re-election and
then it gets worse because President
Trump then calls up his own aides people
who work for him to testify that he did
not throw a tantrum well if you're
trying not to appear volatile probably
the worst way to do this is to get your
own employees come on over here Bob and
tell them I'm not volatile come on over
here tell them I'm not crazy
Jim you work for me tell them I'm not
crazy this is not the way to do this
here's the president doing this was my
temperament yesterday
[Music]
alive Mercedes you're always straight
talker you were in that room yesterday
what was my what was my attitude
yesterday admit versus right now the
answer when you were very calm
no do you laugh or do you cry I mean
really mr. president if you do not want
to appear volatile if you don't want to
appear like a crazy person probably what
you shouldn't do is appeal to all the
people who work for you to testify as to
what a great dude you are all right
let's say that somebody called me
volatile you know what I probably
wouldn't do is call in my producers I
wouldn't call in Nick and both mics I
wouldn't call in my producers and then
say guys tell them I'm not volatile tell
them right now tell them I'm a wonderful
boss that just what what like how is
this in any way strategically smart
again I get it emotionally I do I'll say
that a thousand times over I get where
the president is coming from emotionally
I get what Trump is coming from but if
the rip on you is that your volatile and
then you proceed to show that your
volatile by calling on Mercedes lap who
works for you and Kellyanne Conway who
shills for you on television to testify
as to your innate genius I don't know
what you how is that productive and then
Trump keeps doubling down he says you
know Nancy Pelosi is a mess again all of
this may be true Nancy Pelosi is a mess
yesterday I played a clip of her on my
radio show in which she is utterly
inarticulate it sounds like she's doing
a Dada s poem from the 1930s with some
jazz music in the background she's not
speaking in complete sentences but I am
a podcast and radio host I'm not the
president who has to get reelected
here's President Trump going after Nancy
Pelosi again you know she's a mess look
let's face it she doesn't understand it
and they sort of feels she's
disintegrating before their eyes she
does not understand it they want to have
her understand it before we it's
finished it's signed as you know
Mexico's approved the deal
has approved the deal and they're
waiting to get a signal for her Pelosi
does not understand the bill she doesn't
understand it even though unions are in
favor of it farmers manufacturers
standing behind going oh my god Trump
concluded this I mean this all goes
under bad Trump honestly like there's
good Trump and bad Trump and my good
Trump bad Trump matrix this is all bad
Trump not because it's morally evil or
anything and president has said some
very immoral things nothing he's saying
here is immoral but it is ill-advised at
the extreme level of ill-advised and
then Trump finishes with his favorite
line he says he's an extremely stable
genius and this is like when people tell
you they're exorbitantly wealthy or
incredibly brilliant when people have to
tell you they very often are not and
when the president when's the last time
you told your friends that you weren't
extremely stable genius here's the
President of the United States doing
that yesterday whatever reason you'll
explain this to me I always got a lot of
publicity choice if I said something
even as a private builder or whatever I
was doing at the time I would get a lot
of publicity and without a lot of
without a lot of trying and I was
against certain things but if you look
and you take a look back you'll see all
of the things that you're talking about
and all of the things that you're asking
about
I was against at that time and I'm still
against I haven't changed very much been
very consistent I'm an extremely stable
genius yeah and obviously he's saying
that a little bit tongue-in-cheek
because the president a stent is a
stand-up comedian but that then opens
the door to Nancy Pelosi doing this a
Nancy Pelosi then tweets at the
president about the extremely stable
genius line she says when the extremely
stable genius start to acting my
presidential I'll be happy to work with
him and infrastructure trade and other
issues now this is supremely cynical
from Nancy Pelosi she's not interested
in working with Trump on anything
her entire goal here is to drag Trump
into this fight to get under his skin to
make him crazy that's what she's trying
to do here and then this now this move
where she says you know I pray for him
he needs an intervention he's engaged in
a cover-up and then as soon as Trump
comes back
and says that she's a mass vennett's
well I was happy to work with him but
then he decided that he wasn't gonna
work with me that routine from Nancy
Pelosi it's really galling and it's
really perturbing but with all of that
said is it smart for president Trump to
jump into a personal catfight with Nancy
Pelosi when here's the thing the image
that he needs to propagate from now
until Election Day is of if not an
extremely stable genius an extremely
stable person or at least a stable
person that would be that would that the
entire Democratic pitch is Trump is too
crazy
the economy is good right now on foreign
policy we're heading in the right
direction
Democrats must create the image that the
president cannot be trusted with power
because he's a crazy person and thus you
must hand it over to old Joe slow old
Joe you remember old Joe that's really
their campaign they should make their
campaign slogan Democratic campaign
slogan 2020 you remember old Joe that's
that's the entire pitch I've been saying
for years the Democratic campaign was
going to be the 1920 warren g harding
campaign it returned to normalcy that
was warren g harding the republican
party's pitch in 1920 Woodrow Wilson had
lost it
he was senile at that point and the
Democratic Party had followed him so far
down the chute that Woodrow Wilson's
wife effectively governed the country as
president of the United States in the
middle of Woodrow Wilson's senility as
of 1919 and so Republicans said okay we
just want normal how about normal again
that's what Democrats are trying to do
in order to make that happen they have
to portray the presidents as abnormal
the president should not be helping them
out in this quest and yet and yet the
president's counterpunching tendencies
lead him to do the wrong thing we'll get
to that in one second first hiring is
challenging there's one place you can go
where hiring is simple fast and smart a
place where growing businesses connect
to qualified candidates that place is
zip recruiters calm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter to get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day there's a reason we use zipper
recruiter right here at the Daily wire
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that's zip recruiter dot-com slash
Dai ly w I re zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire go check them out right
now the smartest way to hire okay so
president Trump finishes his attacks on
Pelosi again justified morally not smart
politically the president finishes
attacks on Pelosi by tweeting out a
video of her stumbling over her words
and there was a lot of talk yesterday
about a doctored video of Nancy Pelosi
that made it look like she was slurring
her words I don't know why you'd have to
dr. video of Nancy Pelosi in order to
come up with that conclusion she
stumbles over her words routinely she
has odd pauses in her verbiage in that
this is one of the effects of being
1,000 years old a Nancy Pelosi has been
doing this for a long time this is not a
shock well the president then tweeted
out a compendium of Nancy Pelosi
stumbling over her words now all of that
may be true it is also true that there
are similar videos of the president
stumbling over his words I will say that
the media coverage of this is insane and
insipid the media coverage was how could
President Trump do something like this
so cruel so terrible they even suggested
that this video was doctored this video
is not doctored these sorts of videos
existed about Barack Obama
I remember them there were these long
montages of Barack Obama just saying oh
like a lot to be like um that huge
montages of Obama's saying that sort of
thing they're the same thing with George
HW Bush as long as video has existed as
long as the capability of cutting video
has existed these sorts of compendiums
are put out trump puts it out and
suddenly it's the worst thing that has
ever happened the president tweeted out
Pelosi stammers through news conference
in all caps and then here is the actual
video of Pelosi stammering through a
news conference custody custody of the
border picture border
everyone and they started making sending
signals the US Mexico Canada if that's
not the accurate okay some people call
it after NAFTA some call it NAFTA too
point-o working together to make past
that knot where with the fat there are
three things there are three things
there are three things there are three
things we're very busy people okay that
three things things she is holding up
two fingers at the time so Trump tweets
that out the media go crazy I will point
out the media have been saying the Trump
is a nutcase who can't speak English for
years and he's the President of the
United States whether they like it or
not is any of this wrong from the it's
not wrong but it is not strategically
advised why assume his comms team has
told them this but they cannot control
him anymore then you can control the
wind that is just not the way this works
meanwhile the president is fighting back
against the allegations that have been
made that the the FBI and CIA and the
Obama administration were targeting him
he is now attempting to declassify a
bevy of materials now I've been saying
for years that the president should
declassify as much as humanly possible
I'm amazed by Democrats who today are
claiming that it's a cover-up when the
president declassified material so just
to review when the president says that
William bar the Attorney General has to
keep certain things classified because
the federal rules of criminal evidence
require that grand jury information not
be released into the public that's a
cover-up so if the president used his
classification properly that's a
cover-up also if the president D
classifies that is a cover-up now the
argument from the left is well he's only
selectively Declassified yeah except he
made the entire Mullah report which he
could have remained classified he meant
that entire thing public he made the
entire thing public so I don't get the
are this is what Adam Schiff has been
saying so Adams chef who a moment ago
was was saying that William bar was ugly
he literally said that on stage
yesterday really classy Adams chef I
defended Adam Schiff against allegations
he was a pencil-neck but Adam Schiff is
out there ripping on William bar and
saying that he he's an ugly human being
Adam Schiff ain't no Brad Pitt my atom
Schiff tweeted out while Trump
Stonewall's the public from learning the
truth about his obstruction of justice
Trump and Barr conspired to weaponize
law enforcement and classified
information against their political
enemies the cover-up has entered a new
and dangerous phase this is unamerican
so what exactly is so an American Trump
is now given by her the power to
declassify intelligence related to the
Russia probe so just to get this
straight Schiff is accusing bar and
Trump of using
classified information against their
political enemies there but this
information is not classified anymore
Trump is declassifying information so is
the complaint that Trump is keeping
things secret or that he is making
things open and the Washington Post
reports today president from his granted
attorney General William Bar full and
complete authority to declassify
government secrets issuing a memorandum
late on Thursday that orders u.s.
intelligence agencies to cooperate
promptly with bars audit of the
investigation into Russia's election
interference in 2016 now the reason that
Trump is issuing that order is because
Trump suspects and it may be right that
there are members of the FBI and the CIA
who are going to attempt not to comply
with his orders not to comply with
Attorney General bar and to throw stone
walls in the into Stonewall bar in this
particular investigation the president
has long suspected that there are
institutional forces working against him
inside the intelligence community the
so-called deep state and there were in
fact those forces working against him
during the 2016 campaign I mean this is
not under controversy Peter struck was
openly texting his mistress Lisa page
about setting up insurance programs
against Trump being elected and talking
about her Trump would never become
president and all of the rest of this I
mean was so bad that the Inspector
General of the DOJ Michael Horowitz
chided struck and struck ended up being
fired according to the post the
president's move gives Barr broad powers
to unveil carefully guarded intelligence
secrets about the Russia investigation
which the Attorney General requested to
allow him to quickly carry out his
review according to the memo the White
House said today's action will ensure
that all Americans learn the truth about
the events that occurred and the actions
that were taken during the last
presidential election and will restore
confidence in our public institutions
now again I think this is a good
strategy I think the president should
have done this a long time ago there are
a lot of complaints that the FISA
warrant against Carter page was
unjustified that was based solely on the
steal dossier that was basically
concocted by Trump's enemies to go after
people who worked with Trump during the
campaign and I've been saying for years
on this program okay so why doesn't the
president just declassify that if that's
true just e-class afiad I am for more
information in the public view by the
way I was for the Mullen report becoming
public I'm still for as much with Muller
report becoming public as is legally
permissible I'm not in favor of any sort
of cover-up I want more in the public
eye not less in the public eye and I am
happy with
president's decision to declassify a lot
of this stuff and to leave bar to do it
I don't think that bar is a political
hack in the way the Democrats are
claiming he is a political hack I think
the president has legit questions I
think Trump has legit questions about
what exactly went down during the Trump
Russia investigation and those questions
are not illegitimate in the way that
that so many Democrats seem to be
suggesting that they are conservative
lawmakers have insisted to friends in
the administration that declassifying
documents will help Trump protect his
presidency and further distance himself
from any political fallout from the
Russia investigation the move is likely
to further anger Democrats who have said
that Barr is using his position as the
nation's top law enforcement official to
aggressively protect the president and
attack his critics again declassifying
material that we've been talking about
for three years seems to me a much
better strategy than allowing selective
leaks of those materials from Congress
from members of the intelligence
community remember Andrew McCabe for
example lost his pension and his job
with the FBI because he was leaking
material to the - I believe is the Wall
Street Journal in The Washington Post
that material happened to be about
Hillary Clinton and the FBI's ongoing
investigation nonetheless if it comes to
selective leaks being made by so-called
members of the deep state versus broad
declassification of materials that we've
been talking about for years I'm very
much in favor of Trump declassifying a
lot of this stuff now is Trump right to
be suspicious about the handling of the
Trump Russia collusion case I think
there are certainly questions to be
asked at this point Aaron Klein has a
really interesting piece over at
Breitbart Aaron is a good reporter and
he has a piece talking about William
bars statements last week so last week
William Bar was appeared on TV and there
he explained that what was interesting
is that this investigation was handled
at the very senior level of these
various departments it wasn't handled
sort of an ordinary fashion thing that
was interesting about this is that this
was handled at a very senior level of
these departments it wasn't handled in
the ordinary way that investigations or
counterintelligence activities are
conducted it was sort of an ad-hoc small
group and most of these people are no
long
with the FBI or the CIA or the other
agencies involved I think there's a
misconception out there that we know a
lot about what happened the fact of the
matter is Bob Muller did not look at the
government's activities as Aaron Klein
points out there was a report from The
Washington Post back in June of 2017
specifically talking about how this
investigation was carried out in a
second I want to talk a little bit about
some of the questions that are legit
about the investigation the Trump
Russian investigation again I am
skeptical of the claims that this thing
was initiated totally in bad faith my my
considered take based on the evidence at
this point is that it may have been
initiated in good faith and then it
quickly morphed into a bad faith effort
that may not have been completely
conscious it was people who are who are
simply looking for evidence that
confirmed their prior biases against
President Trump and that's how that
investigation seemed to proceed I'll get
to that in just a second first we the
people holsters offers custom-made
holsters all produced in the United
States they designed their own holsters
in-house that means they don't use any
third-party molds for their holsters
instead they design every unique mold in
Las Vegas in order to best fit each and
every firearm perfectly they're
constantly updating designs they add new
designs every month that lets them stay
up to date on the newest models that
come out these holsters are fantastic I
have one we the people holsters even
have their own 3d design team they
measure every micro millimeter of their
guns to ensure the perfect fit their
unique intuitive clip design allows for
you to easily adjust both the cans and
the right of your holster so that it
will fit comfortably and securely at all
times
every holster also has an adjustable
retention which is signaled with a click
sound and once you know that your
firearm is securely in place which seems
pretty important if ever you want more
tension you can just tighten one screw
and you are done custom printed designs
are made in-house then blue lines in red
line Constitution camo an American flag
more coming out every month we the
people holsters start out at just 37
bucks apiece
every holster comes with a lifetime and
guarantee every holster strips free that
is a fantastic deal for a top-notch
holster right now listeners of the Ben
Shapiro show can go to we the people
holsters comm slash Ben and roll promo
clip Bennett checkout you get ten bucks
off your first holster such as low as 37
bucks shipping is free an additional ten
bucks offer off your first hole start
using my promo code solid deal for a
great holster again that's We the People
holsters comm slash Ben promo code Ben
and check out for 10 bucks off so why
exactly would president Trump and
William Barr be suspicious of the way
which the Trump Muller investigation was
pursued I think one of the reasons
they'd be suspicious is because as Barr
says this thing was pursued at the top
levels of the Obama administration Aaron
Klein over at the Washington over at
over at Breitbart points out a
Washington Post article published in
June 2017 according to that report CIA
director John Brennan convened a secret
Task Force at CIA headquarters composed
of several dozen analysts and officers
from the CIA the NSA and the FBI
apparently the unit was so secretive it
functioned as a quote unquote sealed
compartment hidden even from the rest of
the US intelligence committee the unit
reported to top officials the newspaper
documented they worked exclusively for
two groups of customers officials said
the first was Obama and fewer than 14
senior officials and government the
second was a team of operation
specialists at the CIA NSA and FBI who
took direction from the Task Force on
where to aim their subsequent efforts to
collect more intelligence on Russia the
number of Obama administration officials
has Harun Klein who are allowed access
to the Russia intelligence was also
highly limited at first only four senior
officials were involved John Brennan the
director of intelligence and James
clapper attorney general Loretta Lynch
and then FBI director James Comey their
aides were all barred from attending the
initial meetings and that gradually that
circle widened to include Biden agendas
were sent to cabinet secretaries and
they arrived in envelopes that
subordinates were not supposed to open
this is not according to Breitbart this
is according to the Washington Post when
closed cabinet sessions on Russia began
in the White House Situation Room in
August the video feed from the main room
was even cut off during meetings so that
aides were not able to see what exactly
was going on behind closed doors does
all of this make you at least a little
suspicious I think it's not unreasonable
to be suspicious that's why
declassification would be useful the
more we see the better at this point and
meanwhile in other news the Theresa May
the Prime Minister of Britain is now
officially making it clear that she has
resigned she's making way for a new
prime minister after she failed to
Shepherd through brexit for folks who
don't remember the the whole brexit
controversy basically the people of
Great Britain voted that they no longer
wish to be part of the European Union
they were sick of the regulations from
unelected bureaucrats at the EU level
they were sick of all of the industrial
regulations and the immigration
regulations that were coming down from
Brussels these were people they had not
voted for and basically they kicked back
they said we're not interested in this
they voted for brexit and then the
politicians in Britain got scared of the
EU because the EU said okay well if you
leave we're not gonna make a deal with
you on trade if you leave then we are
basically gonna blackmail you and the
politicians in Britain said well we're
scared of that so we're not gonna leave
basically and they kept proposing deal
after deal after deal they kept being
rejected deal after deal after deal may
finally turned it in the keys to the car
she basically said I can't do this
anymore I don't have any deals on the
table I am capable of pushing at this
point here she was today explaining why
she's leaving and will always remain a
matter of deep regret to me that I have
not been able to deliver brexit it will
be for my successor
to seek a way forward that honors the
result of the referendum I will shortly
leave the job that it has been the honor
of my life to hold the second female
prime minister but certainly not the
last I do so with no ill will but with
enormous and enduring gratitude to have
had the opportunity to serve the country
I love yes obviously she's pretty upset
about everything that's been going on
she was trying to negotiate a deal like
in her defense she was trying to
negotiate a deal that allowed Britain to
keep a lot of the trade benefits of
being part of the EU without keeping
some of the regulations and she
presented a deal that was insufficient
she kept presenting it over and over
people kept voting it down the people of
Britain want out how do we know they
want out because in new polls the brexit
party which did not exist until five
minutes ago led by Nigel Faraj has
become sort of an American fixture in
media thanks to the popularity of brexit
Nigel Farage is now leading in the polls
his party is getting more voters
combined than conservative and labour
which is an amazing amazing statement
right now now is he gonna end up being
Prime Minister probably not probably the
Conservative Party is now going to
nominate somebody to put forward
somebody at the top of their list like
Boris Johnson the former Mayor of London
who is this very colorful figure almost
a trump-like figure at the head of of
their party who will likely be the next
prime minister he's the odds-on
favourite in betting markets to be the
next prime minister of Britain his sole
job will be delivered to
deliver brexit if that's a clean brexit
it's a it's a so-called No Deal brexit
than it's a No Deal brexit meaning they
don't make a pre-existing arrangement
with you
they just say we're out and I think that
what may was trying to mitigate against
was leaving and then there are some
economic consequences to that because
the EU tries to punish the UK for
leaving and at that point the
conservative party pays the price for
having implemented brexit but it's
obvious that her own party wants it she
can't stand up to her own party it's the
people of Britain want this and they are
sick of being told by their political
class not to move forward this we spoke
yesterday on our radio show with douglas
Carswell who was the founder of vote
leaving a former member of the UK
independent party and he discussed the
fact that all of this was eventually
going to lead to the people of Britain
getting what they wanted there was a
referendum that referendum remains
popular that referendum was to leave the
EU and the remainders who are much of
the political class are simply not up
for it Carswell by the way is not a
trade restriction ax so there's been a
lot of lying press about what exactly
brexit is designed to do that brexit is
designed to basically a rectal wall
around Britain or something like that I
know many of the of the leaders of the
brexit movement including people like
Daniel Hannan who was pushing to
eliminate his own job he was a member of
the EU Parliament and he was pushing to
eliminate his own job and he's been
saying for a long time he's a free
trader but having a free trade
relationship with the EU does not
require you to accept Brussels his
determination on who gets to be who gets
to live in Britain for example the may
said she said that she said quote I
believe it was right to persevere even
when the odds against success seemed
high it is and will always be a matter
of deep regret I have not been able able
to deliver brexit so she now joins a
series of conservative prime ministers
who have fallen over the question of
Britain's relationship with Europe David
Cameron John Major Margaret Thatcher all
of them were ousted in part because they
could not get their party to agree on
how closely tied Britain and the
continent should be according to the
Washington Post may had spent two years
negotiating in secret a brexit
withdrawal deal with the EU only to see
it rejected three times by the House of
Commons many of her own conservatives
refused to support her earlier this week
she was still vowing to push on offering
a tweets version of her brexit plan it
was rejected so swiftly and resoundingly
by so many lawmakers including members
of her own cabinet it became clear that
she was going to be ushered out very
very soon there
bunch of people who are jockeying for
position inside the inside the
Conservative Party as I say Boris
Johnson who once said that his chances
of being Prime Minister are about as
good as the chances of finding Elvis on
Mars is the current favorite and opinion
polls and betting markets to become the
next British prime minister on Friday
Johnson came forward and complimented me
on a very dignified statement he tweeted
his thanks to her for her stoical
service and said it was now time to
follow her dreams to come together and
deliver brexit Nicola Sturgeon is a
leader of the Scottish National Party
and and added that that Johnson was some
form of hypocrite Johnson is popular
with the conservative grassroots he
served two terms as mayor of London
which traditionally votes labour proving
he has some cross party appeal he lost
support in some circles after the 2016
referendum he put himself forward as the
face of the brexit campaign he served as
foreign secretary under me but he had
already left anybody who is still
basically in this cabinet is not going
to be Prime Minister anymore other
possible contenders former brexit
secretary Dominic Raab Environmental
Secretary Michael Gove Rob is sort of
the outsider pick to be Prime Minister
if it is not Boris Johnson any lawmaker
can put their name forward as long as
they have the backing of two
conservative members of parliament so
it'll be interesting to see where they
go from here it is obvious though that
the people of Britain have effectively
rejected and Conservative Party members
have effectively rejected the idea of
some sort of soft deal with the EU which
hopes to govern them from above and
frankly good for them good for them I
was in favor of as much as I followed it
I was in favor of brexit and the British
people voted for what they want and they
should get it alrighty so in a second
we're gonna get to the news that that
Julian Assange is now being prosecuted
under the Espionage Act will talk about
the complications inherent in that sort
of prosecution first with all the hype
about Alabama and the never ending
Russia investigation may miss the recent
study in the journal Cell Metabolism I
know I know it's not like it's not your
favorite reading but scientists have
suspected a correlation between growing
rates of obesity and processed foods
what this study discovered was that
these foods also appear to lead people
to overeat the bottom line is this you
need fresh fruits and vegetables in your
diet that's why I recommend you start
taking field of greens by Brickhouse
nutrition just one scoop of field of
greens has a full serving of real USDA
certified organic fruits and vegetables
it helps boost your immunity using
antioxidants prebiotics and
probiotics this is real food it's not
just fake supplement lab powder just
read the nutrition facts panel on the
side right now get 15% off your first
order when you go to brick house been
calm and use the offer code been you
know you're not gonna start clicking
fresh vegetables and fruit every day so
let's not pretend get one full scoop of
fruits and one full scoop of vegetables
every day with field of greens
Brickhouse been calm it's a healthier
way to live in big in nutrition is a
great product
Brickhouse been calm that's brick house
been calm remember to use offer code Ben
for the special deal brick house been a
brick house brick house been calm go
check it out right now okay in a second
we'll get to julian assange the the
prosecution against him on espionage
charges we'll get to that plus we'll get
to the mailbag first you're gonna have
to go over and subscribe
daily wire comm 999 a month get the
subscription right now you get all sorts
of goodies you have a sunday special but
newt gingrich coming up this Sunday you
get it on Saturday you get two
additional hours of the show every
single day which is a lot of content you
also get access to our daily water
backstage we're doing one next week you
get access to all sorts of goodies you
get to be part of our mailbag which
we're gonna be doing momentarily then
all these things can be yours for the
low low price of $9.99 a month or on an
annualized basis ninety nine dollars a
year which as you may know I know you're
doing the mental math right now that is
cheaper than the monthly subscription if
you annualize that monthly subscription
you get this leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr which is magnificent look at it
you hold it
gaze upon it enjoy it but you'll enjoy
it more if you have one go check it out
right now over at daily wire comm also
please subscribe and leave us a review
at YouTube at iTunes that always helps
with our rankings we were the second
largest podcast in America overall
according to pod track last month helped
us get to number one by going over to
YouTube and watching telling all your
friends about it we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so meanwhile in other news
the DOJ is now accusing Julian Assange
of violating the Espionage Act according
to Politico the Justice Department has
hit WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange
with Espionage Act charges escalating a
legal fight against the high profile
activist alarming press freedom
activists the DOJ had previously only
indicted Assange on a single count of
conspiracy to commit computer intrusion
Thursday's revelation of the additional
18 charges filed in the Eastern District
of Virginia means that Assange could
face significantly more prison time if
found guilty the alleged Espionage Act
violations were late to Assange his
complicity with Chelsea Manning Bradley
Manning a former US Army soldier who was
convicted in July 2013 of violating the
Espionage Act after she he shuttled
troves of classified government
information to WikiLeaks officials said
that Assange solicited the information
from and then brazenly published details
that put the government's human sources
at risk now the original charges
suggested that Assange was working with
Manning to actually hack the government
and that was the original charge and
that charge may or may not have been
sustainable now they are charging him
under the Espionage Act now
traditionally the Espionage Act has been
used against government officials like
Manning because if you are a traitor to
the United States who decides to hack
into classified information and then
reveal it to the public you're violating
public trust you are not allowed to
treat classified material that way
unless you happen to be Hillary Clinton
but under the Espionage Act it's been
pretty controversial whether you can
prosecute a quote-unquote journalist for
publishing that material so for example
in the Pentagon Papers case the Pentagon
Papers case surrounded the release of
the the Pentagon Papers which were these
secret studies about Vietnam by the New
York Times the court the Supreme Court
rejected the government's attempts to
prevent the New York Times and The
Washington Post from publishing a leaked
copy of a top-secret study of the
Vietnam War the court had an opinion it
simply said that the government had not
met its heavy burden of justifying a
prior restraint on publication so in
other words they couldn't say
preemptively that the New York Times in
Washington Post could not publish
however the Court did say that you might
be able to punish somebody after the
fact for having published prior
restraints require a greater burden of
proof than punishment after the fact
also you have to ask what kind of
classified material is being published
is it classified material that does
damage to the United States
in sort of dense ones of PR or does it
actually put human beings at risk so for
example Justice Potter Stewart who wrote
a concurring opinion in that case he
said he was convinced that the executive
is correct with respect to some of the
documents involved but I cannot say the
disclosure of any of them will surely
result in direct immediate and
irreparable damage to our nation or its
people well that's not the case with a
lot of the documents that were promoted
by WikiLeaks they included actual
material sources of intelligence the
names of people who are cooperating with
Americans in Afghanistan in Iraq and put
people's lives at risk the State
Department begged Assange not to release
that stuff Assange went ahead and
released that stuff anyway now one thing
that's always been very fuzzy is do the
press have does this mean that the press
have some sort of different rights than
any other normal human being like
freedom of the press under the First
Amendment is not a suggestion that you
get a badge that says journalists on it
and now you have extra rights freedom of
the press means that the government
cannot stop you from printing things
however can the government stop you from
revealing classified information that
endangers American soldiers overseas the
answer that is probably yes the answer
that otherwise they couldn't really
prosecute anybody for even hacking into
America's documents and then revealing
them like why there should be a
journalistic exception to this rule is
beyond me
however the government should in fact
have to prove that the material that
they seek to restrict is is presenting a
serious danger because otherwise you
can't have any government oversight at
all you can't have whistleblowers you
can't have leaker as you can't have any
of that stuff so this does present a
serious constitutional issue one of the
issues also is whether Julian Assange is
entitled to those protections given the
fact that Julian Assange may in fact be
basically a Russian front if Julian
Assange is a Russian front then this is
not just a matter of a quote-unquote
journalist revealing information then
it's a matter of an enemy party
revealing information about the United
States directed at damaging the United
States it raises all sorts of kind of
fascinating legal issues there's a
really interesting piece from a few
years back from the reporters committee
for freedom of the press about WikiLeaks
and in that piece they basically suggest
that journalists have never been
successfully prosecuted under the
Espionage Act so the question is going
to be whether Asajj changes that
precedent whether he can be successfully
prosecuted under the Act Barack Obama by
the way repeatedly
invokes the Espionage Act in order to
prosecute people he prosecuted something
like seven people under the Espionage
Act
they weren't journalists whose people
leaking to journalists so the question
is is a science journalist is a Shan is
this Angelique er was he participating
in the hack that's the real question
here but it's kind of fascinating
because obviously Assange raises serious
press freedom issues and and as I say I
don't think this is unique to the Trump
administration the attempt by the press
to play this as Trump cracking down on
the press because he doesn't like Julian
Assange I was there like five minutes
ago when President Trump was praising
WikiLeaks so this is not personal animus
that Trump has against Julian Assange or
anything like that or personal animus
for the DOJ against WikiLeaks WikiLeaks
has been an extraordinarily dangerous
player in this space for a decade at
this point alrighty it's time for some
mailbag because it is a Friday so let's
jump right in javi says hi Ben I'm a 17
year old high school student at a school
that is about 99% leftist not liberal in
Los Angeles I've been listening to you
almost every day for about a year I
wanted to say thank you for everything
you do my question is I just gave a full
pro-life statement to my high school
newspaper and I'm wondering if you have
any advice on how I can weather the
storm I'm sure to receive from
classmates friends and even teachers
they'll call me all sorts of names and
attack my character thank you well I
mean this is a character building
exercise dude I gotta say you know as
somebody who's been in the public eye
since I was basically 17 years old your
age you you think that you've gone to
fix skin and then you realize every five
minutes that you need to grow another
layer of skin I mean at this point I
basically look like the thing in terms
of personality from the Fantastic Four I
mean you just grow layers and layers of
thicker and thicker skin and so you look
like a rock human that's that's that's
effectively what you have to do here
you're gonna take hits but that is what
being in the arena is all about just
stand strong I would say don't cloud
your way to insult anybody
it's not a rule that I've always kept
myself but most of my regrets happen to
be insulting people that I look back and
I say well that's probably it's not
something I should have done and
something I've been trying to work on
myself so if I've advice to young people
it is only speak when you are
particularly sure of what you are saying
make sure that you're a double sure of
what you are saying because the fact is
that we now live in a media environment
where anything you say publicly when
you're 16 or privately as it turns out
when you're 16 or 17 years old can be
used against you by your political
opponents so you just have to
be extraordinarily careful and also try
to cultivate a level of character that
you wish that your opponent's had so try
not to engage in character attacks
instead debunk arguments and if they
engage in a character attack then you
are fully you are fully justified in
saying that they are being a jerk that
you are fully justified in sayings I've
said for years and I continue to
maintain if somebody attacks your
character you have no obligation to sit
there and take it you are fully
justified in responding by saying that
they are badly motivated you are fully
justified in saying that they are acting
like a jackass you are fully justified
in doing all of those things when
somebody attacks your character don't be
the first person to attack character
attack political point of view instead
Rohan's has been new subscriber here I
have a question regarding a recent book
in the book you argue the
judeo-christian morality and Greek
natural law built the foundation for
scientific progress in the West if this
is true what about other civilizations
such as ancient China and India these
civilizations made important discoveries
as well but did not have the same
foundation as the West also the Roman
Empire made great technological advances
before judeo-christian influence thank
you for all you do best
Rohan well the truth is that the the
vision of modern science the idea of
hypothesis and hypothesis being rejected
by evidence that sort of science
experimental science is unique to the
West there's a difference between
technological progress which does exist
in a vast number of civilizations and
that technological progress is generally
linked to the human need to overcome the
environment around them there's a
difference between that and the pure
idea of exploring science for its own
sake which then has technical
applications later that is something
that seems fairly unique to the West
which is why you see thinkers in the
West like Isaac Newton who are who are
trying to figure out general rules of
the universe in a way that very few
people were doing in other civilizations
that doesn't mean that every other
person and every other civilization was
incapable of doing this obviously there
were strides in science and mathematics
particularly in the Indian world as in
like India in the Indian world in the
first millennia but in the first
millennium but the great expanse of
science was deeply wedded to
historically speaking the the
judeo-christian belief that in order to
investigate God you had to investigate
God's universe and that was tied to a
Greek natural law evidentiary based
position that the way to discover
natural rule
was to look at the evidence I mean it's
an Aristotelian idea so as I say this is
not to discount any of the discoveries
of other civilizations the question is
why the West did it best and the answer
is that the West did it best not just
because they were making technological
advances against technological advances
exist throughout history the question is
why is it that the West came up with
this idea of science this generalized
idea of science which was then used to
create tremendous technological change
far beyond what you get if you were just
in a field and you needed to figure out
how to make a plough work better for
example there's a difference between
generalized science and technological
and kind of incremental technological
change Leu i says heaven it's my
birthday can I get a shout out you just
did my friend Michael says Ben what do
you think of the post-keynesian argument
that says government deficit spending as
long as we're not at full employment is
a net positive on the economy that is
putting more money into the economy than
it's taking out while surplus is our net
drain since the government is taxing
more out than it is spending back in
well I don't believe in government
surplus is a general rule I don't think
that the government should be taking in
money unless they intend on using that
surplus for something useful a
government surplus is effectively the
government confiscating wealth from
people that they do not use and that
seems to me a confiscation that is
unjustified as far as the the
post-keynesian argument the the general
argument that government deficit
spending is inherently a good that
widespread government deficit spend
deficit spending is inherently a good
it's good until it's not there just like
credit card spending is good until it's
not it's great you can buy all sorts of
stuff and then the credit card bill
comes in and then things go to hell in a
handbasket right now the United States
is riding on the fact that we are the
most powerful economy in the world and
in world history
that there are no near rivals for it and
thus the dollar remains strong people
continue to invest in our bonds and all
of the rest that's true so long as we
don't radically regulate our economy
raise taxes engage in green New Deal
type Salinas but there will come a point
where people are gonna recognize that 21
trillion dollars in debt ain't getting
paid off anytime soon and when that
happens then we're cruisin for a bruisin
Joshua says hey Ben
so I'm currently serving the military
looking for a new career when I exit
first of all thank you so much for your
service you're doing something I didn't
do I have nothing but admiration and and
really respect for that law has been
something I've always been interested in
I was wondering what
you could recommend to learn the basics
of constitutional law and/or criminal
law thanks well criminal law I mean
there are some pretty good criminal law
textbooks that are out there I would say
in terms of constitutional law some of
my favorite books on constitutional law
include a matter of interpretation by
Justice Scalia very slim volume that
sort of explains constitutional theory I
disagree with him about sorry decisis
but his general take on how to read
constitutional text is correct I think
that you should check out Robert Bork's
attempting of America which is really
nice history of the court and what
exactly the court has done throughout
American history the mark levin has a
really good simplified version I think a
Bork's book called men in black from
maybe 15 or 20 years ago that's a pretty
good synopsis of court of how the courts
have usurped power all that stuff is
pretty good and then obviously read the
basics the Federalist Papers read the
Constitution itself the Heritage
Foundation has a wonderful guide for the
to the Constitution with case references
and everything I'd recommend going and
picking that up from Amazon Robbie says
hey Ben
why isn't making adoption more
affordable at the top of the most
Republican policies
I know Alabama where I live is kicking
butt at adoption in the state right now
my wife and I have looked into ourselves
a few times the financial side can be
pretty daunting generally I'm in favor
of government being involved in it as
little as possible but can it be
considered conservative ii think the tax
dollars should go towards taking care of
orphans and putting them in a loving
home trying to reconcile my feelings on
adoption with my small government
feelings shapiro Haley 2024 so as far as
as making adoption simpler yes
regulations on adoption should be
largely relieved people should be it
should be easier for people to adopt as
far as tax incentives being driven
toward adoption you know I think that
the I think the tax rates generally
should be lowered as a libertarian I'm
not generally in favor of the government
quote-unquote promoting policy via tax
dollars with that said you know we do
have a tax system that right now has to
care for people who cannot take care of
themselves and that going toward the
taking care of orphans and then shifting
them toward adoptive homes seems like a
not terrible idea to me Jacob says hey
man I just graduated from law school
last week and any stories or tips you
can share on how to study for the bar
exam memorize memorize memorize I mean
that is all the bar exam is it is just
an enormous amount of memorization so
sit down with your text with with I
always
use flashcards make a bunch of
flashcards and then just drill yourself
on the flashcards brian says hey but I
was wondering your opinion on Edward
Snowden is he hero or an enemy to the
United States do you think he should be
pardoned also do you think of Edward
Snowden changed his name and sex like
Manning's you think he would have gotten
a pardon from Obama - well apparently
that was the pattern because there was
no reason for Chelsea Manning to
actually be pardoned Chelsea Manning was
not in any way contrite about having
hacked US classified materials and then
exposed it to WikiLeaks so Chelsea
Manning should still be sitting in jail
obviously when it comes to Edward
Snowden I think two things can be true
at once one some of the information we
got from Edward Snowden was important
for the public to know and to Edward
Snowden is not a hero Edward Snowden was
pretty obviously working with the
Russian government and Edward Snowden
which is why he tried to take refuge in
Russia and Edward Snowden I do not think
he's a good guy so good people can
sometimes bad people can sometimes give
you material that you need this does not
make you a hero it means that you did
something that is wrong but it revealed
good information to the public this does
happen on occasion so the answer is sort
of both I don't think it's a don't think
it's heroism to hack America's
classified documents and they had them
over in bulk to people who do not care
about America's national security at the
same time I'm glad some of that stuff is
available to the American public's and
we know the extent of the government's
surveillance upon us okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today so
this is a stupid wonderful movie the
movie is Olympus has fallen I know it's
old I was only made aware of this
recently sunny bunch who I will admit is
my favorite movie reviewer he said that
Olympus has fallen was a great movie
which is to say that it was going to be
retrograde and politically incorrect and
all the rest and the movie basically is
it's effectively the movie is just it's
basically the movie is just die hard in
the White House except without half the
clever dialogue that's all the movie is
and it's fun it's really fun also I
happen to really like Gerard Butler I
like internet cart so here's a little
bit the trailer mr. president
five minutes sir evening ma'am Merry
Christmas Mike Mustang this is big table
bringing out the full
[Music]
where'd that come from
everybody knows you did the right thing
on that bridge even the president knows
okay the film is is it's so silly and
yet it's so kind of great it's it's if
basically if Bruce Willis didn't have
anything witty to say a die-hard this is
the film but it's it's kind of clever
and fun you can go check out Olympus has
fallen I haven't seen London who's
falling in I've heard it's even more
reactionary so that means that I'll
probably have to watch it okay time for
some things that I hate okay thing that
I hate number one so Stacey Abrams
continues to trot around claiming that
she's the actual governor of Georgia I
mean this is just this is just crazy
towns at this point at a certain point
you do have to accept the reality that
you lost the Georgia election by some
55,000 votes
that's not supremely close that's 55
that's a lot of votes she still is
walking around like she is governor of
Georgia it's it's it's astonishing I
mean it really is this is now reached
the delusional what she's about to say
right here is delusional on so many
levels it's almost it's like an onion of
delusion it's like you just continue to
carve into the onion and there are more
layers of delusion beneath the layers of
delusion here's Stacey Abrams
a woman who is being thought of as a
possible VP contender on the basis of
losing a Georgia gubernatorial race
talking about how she's the actual
governor of Georgia and how she won in
this coalition of new and engaged who
are in this pursuit of progress we have
to recognize that the internal threat we
face is the fear of who we are the
notion of identity politics has been
peddled for the last 10 years and it's
been used as a dog whistle to say that
we shouldn't pay too much attention to
the new voices coming into progress I
would argue that identity politics is
exactly who we are and it's exactly how
we won by centering communities in
Georgia we not only increase voter
participation we brought new folks to
the process identity politics isn't just
who we are it's how we won one you
didn't you lost second of all identity
politics is not who we are if you're a
rational human being you try to get
beyond the identity politics you try to
get beyond the notion that you are just
what your group identity says that you
are that you are not merely a person who
is quote unquote born a Jew
technically or born black in the case of
Stacey Abrams then instead you are
supposed to find a set of ideas that you
wish to espouse and then dig and then
have discussions about those ideas with
others this is the basis of a republic
particularly a multi-ethnic Republic if
you're gonna have a multi-ethnic
Republic in which everybody sort of
revert back to their own innate genetic
identity and that's the only argument
that you can make you can't have a
republic so layers of delusion from
Stacey Abrams the fact that she's been
so wildly praised by the media is is
absolutely astonishing to me she may be
a good speaker but she is also at this
point engaged in tremendous levels of
delusion and other things that I hate
John Walker Lindh the American Taliban
is out so that's great so John Walker
Lindh you'll remember all the way back
from the beginning of the war on terror
he was seventeen he left his home in
California in 1998 to study Arabic in
Yemen he then went to Pakistan in 2000
and then he went to Afghanistan and he
served as a Taliban volunteer in
al-qaeda training camp and then he was
held in a prison near Mzee a
mazar-e-sharif in afghanistan where an
uprising claimed the first u.s. casualty
of war a 32 year old CIA officer named
Johnny Michael span span was killed
after questioning Lindh although the
government didn't offer evidence that
Lynne had participated in the revolt at
trial he pled guilty to charges of
providing support to the count Taliban
and carrying a rifle and a grenade now
in days past this person would have been
put up against a wall and shot for
treason now he gets put in jail taking
care of for 20 years and then let out
despite the fact that according to the
National Counterterrorism Center Lynn
had quote continued to advocate for
global jihad and to write and translate
violent extremist texts that says of
2017 another 2017 assessment from the
Bureau of Prisons said he had made
supportive statements about the Islamic
state yeah that is not good US policy to
be letting people I mean he hasn't even
served his full sentence the sentence
was 20 he served 17 this is madness I
the good news is that eventually he'll
end up as a professor at a major
American University because that's
pretty much all it takes these days is
to hate America with a deep and abiding
passion alrighty we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
Ben Shapiro show or we'll see you here
on Monday and have a wonderful weekend I
mention para this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19